Oranges or in soda or
a sickles orange roles.
We're surrounded by oranges.
They're in our bathrooms,
in our kitchens and even on
our clothes and as a color,
they're founded even more places. In
fact, if I didn't look so bad in orange,
I probably be wearing an
orange shirt right now,
but what are the origins
of the word orange?
The word originally comes from the
Dravidian peoples of ancient India.
It was later borrowed into Sanskrit as
Nevada and then the fruit and the word
made its way into Persia.
After that,
it worked it's way farther west into the
Arabic speaking countries where it was
known as not Onj.
Spanish speakers may recognize this as
a cognate with the Spanish word not on
and the early 1300 Arab traders brought
a bitter orange later known as the
Seville orange from the Middle East
to Sicily and the fruit quickly spread
throughout the rest of Europe.
It was in Italian and French that the
word originally lost its initial end sound
through a process known
as the med analysis or re
bracketing Italians indefinite
article ending with the same sounds as
the first two letters of the word not on
absorb the initial end sound.
Nina not ONJ became, Ooh,
not on chef. And even more
understandably when the French bottle,
the word into their language,
the boundary between the article and
the word not ONJ became all too unclear.
You know, home became, you know, home.
They're pretty much
pronounced exactly the same.
The process is called re bracketing
precisely because the word boundaries are
changed.
They're re bracketed there redefined
where once the boundary between words
existed here,
it was later put here to give you a
better idea of just how easy this is to
happen,
especially in a world where coming across
the word and writing would have been
exceedingly more rare.
Try saying the following,
an orange and orange,
they're pronounced almost exactly the
same and careful speech and exactly the
same in casual speech. So when the French
began to use this new and exotic word,
primarily in speech, some new,
they were saying in the home,
but others heard it as you know,
honk.
And it's here when the word enters
the English language by a French as an
orange.
It was later in the 16th century when the
word had already spread throughout all
of Europe.
That the sweet orange,
the orange we know and love today was
brought from China to Europe by Portuguese
merchants and later to the
Americas by the Spanish.
It is also around this time when we begin
to see the word used to describe the
color and tell next time,
orange,
you glad I didn't tell a
cheesy joke about oranges.